nihlus the gorilla famous for walking on
two legs may be able to teach us why
people do the same video of luis
casually strutting around on two legs at
the Philadelphia Zoo went viral zoo
officials say his two limb approach
helps prove just how smart gorillas are
Don Dahler is at the Philadelphia Zoo to
explain what this unusual primate
behavior really means Don taking notes
yeah I'm good morning there he is that's
Luis he's just hanging out before he
starts his day resting a little bit he's
been a start here at the Philadelphia
Zoo for 14 years but when they posted
that video he gained national attention
researchers say his upright behavior
might be a clue as to why humans evolved
to walk on two feet Luis is not like his
fellow playmates
weighing in at a hefty four hundred and
seventy pounds and standing at nearly 6
feet tall the 18 year old gorilla
sometimes prefers to stand on two legs
rather than on all fours gorillas will
occasionally stand up for a few seconds
or walk a couple of steps but what we
see Luis doing is really walking clear
across the yard and that's quite special
Michael Stern is a curator at the
Philadelphia Zoo
he says Luis walks upright for a number
of different reasons in the video he
does have his hands full of tomatoes
which is one of his favorite treats and
I think he just doesn't want to crush
them by knuckle-walking so he stands up
and walks he'll also do it more if the
yard is muddy for whatever reason he
does not like the feel of mud on his
hands and he just likes to stand up and
walk sometimes gorillas have about 98
percent the same DNA as humans it is
that 2% difference that separates their
intelligence and how they walk for apes
it's usually more efficient to walk on
all four however there is individual
variation I would guess that for Luis
it's not very difficult at all I think
it comes quite naturally to him and Luis
is not alone a 27 year old gorilla in
England named ambam made headlines in
2011 for his own human-like strut both
Lewis and ambam walk upright to more
effectively gather food which scientists
say may be one of the reasons humans
evolved to walk on two feet gorillas are
such intriguing animals and you can tell
immediately when you look into their
is that they are so similar to us that
they are so intelligent and yet there is
something so animalistic about them and
powerful so when you see one acting even
more human by walking upright like that
it just makes you realize wow those
those are pretty amazing animals the
world is amazing nature is amazing
despite his enormous size the folks here
at the zoo tell me that he's actually
quite shy and he hates to get dirty in
fact he's been seen using leaves or even
paper bags to clean his hands and his
feet they stretched a fire hose across a
muddy part of his enclosure which he
uses as a tightrope to avoid getting
messy John Donne thank you yeah like
everything about Louis on top of that
he's clean too the neat freak his
birthday party walk around a tree but
it's interesting to see the two gorillas
with two different walking styles right
yes very nice done thank you